[Musik]
hey was geht ab und willkommen bayern
ein video arbeite ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut er heute ist es endlich
soweit heute wird zumindest schon mal
das iphone verloren bzw springs hat
persönlich vorbei das gewinnspiel ist
hier noch von vor weihnachten oder genau
weihnachten ist stirbt genau an
heiligabend kam das online und habe
würde ich selbst fleißig kommentiert
eigentlich wollte ich das ganze schon
längst hinter mir haben als ich wollte
längst wenn jemandes iphone geben
das ding war nur prüfung geschrieben und
hatte wirklich keine zeit dafür
irgendwie einfach mal jedem 2 300
kilometer zu fahren um jemanden iphone
zu übergeben deswegen machen wir das
erst heute was ich auf jeden fall auch
noch kurz erklären muss ich habe dem
gewinner eigentlich erst mal bei youtube
geschrieben so da kam keine antwort dann
habe ich ihm wieder geschrieben kamen
wieder keine antwort weil es nicht
gesehen hat irgendwie dann habe ich eine
neue gewinnerin ausgewählt kam auch
keine antwort über youtube und dann habe
ich heute jetzt aufgerufen bei cnet
schüttelt minister gehören das hier
bitte nochmal mit eurem instagram namen
kommentieren sollte weil ich das jetzt
einfach mal loswerden muss ich mein
sonst lenkte nachher das war fake oder
so das will ja auch nicht und jetzt habe
ich gerade die ganze dran gesessen und
eine gewinnerin ausgesucht und die habe
ich auch schon kontaktiert und da fragen
wir jetzt gleich hin ist auf jeden fall
nicht um die ecke aber gut ich habe eh
nichts zu tun so leute ich zeige euch
mal kurz wir den chartverlauf und zwar
habe ich ihren foto geschickt wenn man
das sieht unterschiede hallo was soll
das jetzt heißen
wtf und jetzt schreibe ich mal also wenn
du möchtest bringe ich dir dass ich
schreibe ich schreib mal also bot das
hat mich so auch bei internet also wenn
du möchtest bringe ich das gleich vorbei
das war wirklich so schwer jemanden
ausfindig zu machen
ich habe das volk nicht durchdacht am
anfang also ich habe jetzt gerade das
iphone iphone acht komplette noch
eingepackt ich kann euch auch malkurse
die anderen sachen zeigen noch über sinn
hier haben wir noch die sofort
kamerateams auch noch weg dann haben wir
hier noch die playstation 4
die muss auch noch weg ich raus war
du bist auch noch weg und dann haben wir
auch noch den lockenstab der muss auch
noch weg für die playstation habe ich
allerdings schon
rausgesucht nur den kann ich heute auf
keinen fall noch besuchen das ist viel
zu weit weg und das soll natürlich
eigentlich auch noch eine überraschung
werden julia hat geschrieben niemals bin
schreibe ich jetzt einfach mal also
julia geschrieben niemals schreiben
jetzt mal okay dann nicht geschrieben
okay dann halt nicht
leute ich war jetzt mal auf die adresse
von julia dann fahrrad einmal vorbei ich
hoffe sie ist heute auch da und dann
sehen wir uns gleich wieder ist gleich
so leute ich habe mich jetzt mit der
julia verabredet ich habe die adresse
bekommen und verweise also wir fahren
jetzt sofort los ich hatte hier noch
einige sachen von der alten weib
kollektionen also hier ist alles voll
und ich habe mir gedacht ich tue einfach
mal noch irgendwas dazu warum nicht zu
viel an dieser stelle vielleicht mal
also wegen den klamotten ich verlinke
euch in der video beschreibung mal den
link zum shop und zwar könnt ihr euch
hier anmelden mit einem newsletter dann
bekommt immer die infos also einfach
drauf gehen eure e mail angeben wir
machen das jetzt nämlich so dass
irgendwann eine neue kollektion
rauskommt die kommt es voraussichtlich
am ersten dritten raus die ist dann nur
für drei oder vier tage online dann
könnt ihr bestellen oder nachts wieder
aufbauen und dann gibt es halt immer so
release daten also geht er einfach mal
drauf meldet euch an und dann verpasst
ihr nichts und ich würde sagen welche
größe und julia wolf
[Musik]
danach war einfach nur niemand von der
polizei ist ja schon so so leute wir
sind jetzt auf den weg und zwar warten
wir jetzt nach hildesheim ich warne vor
einer nie
ich wusste erst nicht lustig das ist
irgendwo in hannover dabei anrufer oder
so wäre es auf jeden fall noch 150 160
km und dann besuchen maria und ich hoffe
julian freut sich über ein iphone 8 ich
würde mich freuen
also wenn man es gerade 60 nur ich bin
mal gespannt wann wir wieder zu hause
sind weder auf jeden fall ein sehr
spontaner lenkrad ich meld nicht wir
müssen jetzt hier ein bisschen gas geben
und
dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder
[Musik]
hey leute schaut euch mal das nicht nur
schönheit
ich frage mich so ist das extra will
oder ist das einfach ein schlechter
zufall
also ich will das nicht ganz so nummer
zu groß mit 900 schöne grüße
so leute wir sind jetzt mittlerweile
angekommen hier in hildesheim sieht sehr
schön aus hier fühlt man sich gleich wie
zu hause zeigt main street tipico ist
auch schon da recht ich glaube man muss
für sportwetten abschließen ja die julia
wurden auch einen kilometer entfernt und
ich bin gespannt ob julia sich freut
leute wir sind jetzt hier bei der julia
in der neo jugendfahrt platz und julia
wohnt weiß ich dich auf jeden fall
ziemlich bergig hier in hildesheim war
julia gleich wieder runter das ist auch
richtig weit weg man sich nur zu fuß
geht das jetzt von hier aus das zu julia
[Applaus]
ok
sollte
ja
[Musik]
ich habe hallo
für das geht ganz schnell
ich hab hier habe ich noch gedacht
[Musik]
danke ich ihnen gerne das ist übrigens
lehnert hat so ein bisschen
ich habe hier so leute das ja nie
funktioniert wie man sieht und julia
freut sich natürlich sehr oder
sie hatten nämlich nur ein kaputtes
songs und finden und hier sind wir in
einem altbau ist ein richtig angreifen
wir haben ein recht ins wasser
gesprungen
wir fordern die definieren wenden
was will man denn mehr einsparen so
leute ziemlich kalt hildesheim aber sehr
schön schaut euch mal diesen teich an
und wird zu hause und nicht kommen wir
jetzt sogar eingefroren da hinten habe
ich gedacht ich muss euch gleich ein
auto zeigen es ist einfach so verging
denke ich weil ich gestern nicht wie du
viel schnee gefahren oder so keine
ahnung auf jeden fall hat es mich sehr
gefreut julia schöne grüße noch mal was
sehr cool vor allem deine mutter auch
sehr nett und danke auch an lennart der
mit gekommen ist deswegen begrüßen oder
so ein spaß
eigentlich wäre jetzt cool gewesen
könnte ich die playstation auch noch
irgendwo loswerden aber da habe ich
leider keine zeit mehr für weil das ist
viel zu weit weg schaut euch mal das
auto an ist es einfach moment komplett
man kann es gar nicht mehr so sind weil
die sonne weg ist aber es ist einfach so
dreckig geworden habe ich eine knöcherne
ach so und wir machen uns jetzt wieder
auf dem weg zurück haben jetzt auf jeden
fall noch 160 170 kilometer vor uns und
ich würde sagen dass er nur das essen
das gleich sechs in den später so leute
wir haben jetzt endlich zu hause
das hat echt noch jahre dauert es
mittlerweile irgendwie halt 9 oder 9 uhr
im moment findet von 9 um 50 um halb
vier sind wir losgefahren also zehn
stunden war auf jeden fall mega cool
auch wenn es sehr anstrengend war und
ich eigentlich nur ein iphone los
geworden wenn die playstation kommt ja
auch noch da natürlich also denkt nicht
die behalte ich oder sich sind wir dann
jetzt auch schon fast meine des videos
vielleicht noch mal kurz hier die ganzen
kartons denkt dran
bald gibt es eine neue produktion
einfach mal gerne vorbeischauen bei dem
shop einfach eine video beschreibung
verlinkt abonniert auf jeden fall den
newsletter kostet natürlich nix
ansonsten hoffe ich natürlich dass
wieder durch gefallen haben wir schöne
grüße an julia ich hoffe du hast dich
gefreut und seit würde nicht traurig
wenn jetzt nicht das iphone gewonnen
haben oder so erfreulich für die julia
mit und ich freue mich natürlich auch
dass es jetzt irgendwie gewonnen hatte
er sich darüber gefreut hat mir gerne
auf instagram oder snapshot und wir sind
uns eventuell schon morgen wieder bei
uns jetzt ein bisschen karneval und
sogar schlägen je nachdem wie man es
nennt habe ich jetzt nicht ganz viel
zeit für videos aber ich gebe mein
bestes also leute wir sehen uns vor 3